[Musica]
chiudete gli occhi vedete il 2013
davanti a voi un piccolo fa vj di cinque
anni fa quasi sei anni fa con una roba
in testa inguardabile che faceva video
su dei giochi molto strani cosa che
succede ancora adesso in particolare la
mia prima serie di successo su questo
canale è stata father via pronuncia
incredibile è un gioco è pg dove c'è
questa bambina come protagonista è molto
simile tipo aliboni quella roba lì non
mi ricordo niente ma proprio zero questi
questo non mi ricordo manco il menu
manco il personaggio iniziale mi ricordo
va beh più o meno mi ricordo che era una
storia bellissima è stata una storia
veramente bellissima voglio
assolutamente giocarla di nuovo tra
l'altro questa qua non è la stessa
versione ma una versione molto
aggiornata perché hanno fatto degli
aggiornamenti non so cosa è una remaster
e quindi probabilmente qualcosa cambia
nella storia non lo so comunque è
diversa da quella che ho fatto io è
nuova vediamo di fare un bellissimo
gameplay
iniziamo allora io devo tradurvi visto
che il gioco in inglese
proverò a farlo ragazzi chiari per
concentrarmi sulla lettura non mi
servono a niente perché ci vedo
benissimo però mi rendono un po più
intellettuale germania del nord
residenza travis papa punti putin
cioè siamo nella germania del nord papa
si qua dentro
ahia ahia nel senso proprio che lei si
chiama così non si è fatto male
quante volte ti devo dire di non venire
po giù scusami papa germania del nord 15
sono sti dottori nazisti ma sono tanto
spaventata da dormire da sola beccano a
casa così venite se non si è spaventata
your light madre perché non so cosa
voglia dire lei sto male comunque è
sempre al tuo fianco
papa domani e si è l'anniversario della
sua morte a vedi che ha la mamma è morta
per questo voleva dire league ma se ti
osserva sempre ed è morta
non è una cosa piuttosto preferirei
stato solo però vabbè ora torna a
dormire per favore tra poco arriverà ho
anch'io prova a farlo un po più smr
storie place avvicina microfono o mio
dio che lo sta facendo mio padre aiuto
aiuto grazie di statista triturando
la sostanza vabbè la bambina tranquilla
in tutto questo c'è il padre che sega la
gente ma fa niente bella sta a casa
comunque fatta molto bene e mezzanotte
oggi è il giorno in cui mai mai andata
in paradiso posso già muovermi posso
toccare le tende che figata allora posso
andare in giro un ritratto di mamma
mamma
queste le vede pure senza occhiali ma ci
sono tre mamme qua non ne vedo una sola
vabbè che cosa farò io mamma mamma
perché te ne sei andata di sicuro non è
morta per incidente stradale perché gli
airbag e giace lì aveva la stanza si
infreddolita tutto d'un tratto sono
spaventata dovrei tornare a dormire va
bene quell'urlo qualcosa deve essere
successo
vado a controllare papa ok let's go così
stato questo rumore era una voce porca
vacca mi sono mezzo cagato anch'io maghi
ciao ragazzi halloween è passato da un
paio di settimane da questa parte che ha
parlato di qui c'è qualcuno lì dove
corri visto che ci sono degli zombie chi
è questo da questa parte hanno fatto il
personaggio il bonaccione sporco di
sangue
i pettorali va bene
beh non so quanto convenga però va bene
credo che lui abbia occhio per queste
cose sono proprio migliorato di comicità
negli ultimi sei anni
vabbè vabbè normali non è in di meglio
da fare gli lasci soli zombie è infatti
però in camera c'e tuoro chi è youlike
brooks my dear lo sapevo non sapevano
che c'aveva questo accento philatélie è
così e sono anche pelato web chiara mio
gre quelli che hai visto sono i corpi
dei test che fa tuo padre e sono stati
riportati da una maledizione
per prendere la vendetta su tuo padre
certo mio padre in pericolo e boe venite
the walking dead
devo andare a salvare papa ai per
salvare la partita questo ragazzo
belloccio a si apre tutto carte alla
scala manca un pezzo
figurati se trova una scala intatta va
bene l'ambientazione fighissima è
veramente [ __ ] tipo dieci volte di
marika league
ridatemi mia figlia ce l'ho io però li
c'è un oggetto posso entrare a prenderlo
che ti giuro che non ti disturbo ecco
grazie trovato la chiave la chiave degli
archivi tanto sono cose in casa tua
queste quindi dovresti sapere che cosa
c'è in casa tua
perché c'è un rumore così strano di
sottofondo tipo qualcuno che pesta la
melma l'orologio si è fermato a
mezzanotte e non è un buon segno chi è
che pesta melme or cava checcoli ciao
amici
devo andare da papà mamma mia il
bruciore culo
devine morta scritto in tedesco e the
skin non capisci una sega in però morder
pensi a omicida c'è qualcosa qui e si lo
vedo somiglia molto a pietro o a tanti
pietre che cos'è non lo so non ci passò
di lì mi sa che è meglio che non ci
passiva e usciamo con le tifoso no relax
non puoi passare se c'è lui però un po
più schifoso l'ex andiamo avanti nei
limiti a docenti così code monio
decentrato la porta permesso io ho
sempre un po di kakà passare davanti a
si sa mai che qualcuno mi ammazza perché
tanto questo sembra che c'ha le cale
braga le calebb regate volevo dire le
braghe calate però non fa niente cos'è
ho sentito qualcuno nel fuoco orca vacca
su un quadro che si muove quadro che si
muove vabbè magari cerca di capire il
perché
a me devo fare la sequenza ogni volta
porta col demonio liberati liberati ok
ce l'ho fatta scappa c'era uno nudo che
mi ha attaccato però non fa niente tipo
gollum
ma è ancora lì no è sparito adesso
abbiamo la partita mi sono salvato per
purissimo la smetti di star lì dentro
vuoi muovere il quadro si dai nuovi lo
sa c'è una stanza didietro perfetto
adesso si che ci entrò lì dentro
voglio vedere cosa c'é qua c'è qualcosa
sopra che aia non riesce a raggiungere
abbia usato sgabello che tanto si muove
da solo quindi muoviamo noi
let's go non mi ricordavo fatto così
bene sto gioco
avevo preso un coltello questo è
utilissimo porca vacca per difendersi da
iaia fi urlare il tuo nome alla gente
sono in giardino però il giardino è
murato quindi come se non ci fosse
niente devo riuscire ad andare avanti
ragazzi so già che così che mi fanno
qualcosa
stai fermo fermo ferma che tu ti te non
mi fido posso lontano bagno e l'ultima
stanza che minima della controllare ed è
sporca di sangue
va bene dagli si giochi in cui ti
tolgono la musica a un certo punto sono
proprio tranquillizzanti grazie
veramente grazie cesso se ti cade
addosso almeno sai dove andare
permesso ecco la vasca non so se se
qualcuno ci aveva le sue cose però papa
non penso visto che un maschietto
devo controllare dentro prendo l'oggetto
prendo l'oggetto prima la chiave della
caffetteria
dentro c'è uno nudo c'è gente nuda in
questo gioco ma niente nome l'ho fatto
kaba meno male visto che non è che
proprio ci tenga a toccare gente nuda la
slow salve sono fa vj no e dove vai
cos'era quella bambola che si muoveva
non lo so chi se ne frega e parte della
valle edizione beh di sicuro non è una
cosa normale sana bambola si muove in
giro che di cda abbiamo la partita prima
che mi ammazzino gli zombie 321 via
scappa veloce che c'è un oggetto han
jackie male tanto se cambio stanza mesi
mi recupera tutta la vita quindi molto
bene
la caffetteria dovrebbe essere questa
qua sotto mi devi fare tipo veloce molto
bene però quasi morto cg scampato
veramente un niente
qui dentro c'è qualcosa sbaglio c'è una
nudo che novità non si sta muovendo e
ringraziando iddio anche non c'è niente
mi scusi devo prendere quell'oggetto lì
non si muova per cortesia perché è una
gemma già messo non solo collezionabili
non servono a niente
abbiamo messo un cane rave news non so
cosa voglia dire ma di sicuro non vuol
dire carino sta divorando il cibo
io lo lascerei lì infatti non è che mi
vada tanto di toccarlo andiamo a
controllare dall'altra stanza molto bene
molto bene
c'era qualcosa sotto capelli una botola
sotto il tappeto vai vai tanto ovunque
meglio che è completamente buio eh beh
non posso andare qui sotto l'abitato
resto della casa non è che sia così
sicuro mi serve e l'accendino qualcuno
un accendino ovvero presta per cortesia
vorrei vedere se riesco a prendere
quell'oggetto in basso ma cos'è una
gemma va a cagare stesso casinò veloce
veloce perché in un sali le scale
normalmente quanto tempo si poteva cose
che il corpo cadaveri di un gatto nel
cassetto
ho letto bene c'era il cadavere di un
gatto nel cassetto è ottimo
questa mia mamma me la ricordo molto
bene posso prendere palla di neve
qui parla di neve o neve ma papavero ho
preso palla di neve veramente c'è un
oggetto nuovo parla di neve di niente
adesso ciò il coniglio ma non ho capito
bene cosa ci devo fare questo coniglio
però vabbè ma dico ci un'altra ala della
casa gli eccoli archivi ma porca vacca
non li avevo visti proprio cielo operato
salve mi scusi l'ho vista né che può
scomparire così provvista che leggevo i
libri uomini nudi e pelati c'è qualcosa
di bloccato qui
premio prendi con codice codice c'è un
bimbo nudo blu con i capelli bruttissimi
che urla mamma aiutami
[Musica]
voglio andare a casa voglio andare a
vedere mamma no ma è orribile raga
veramente non ti preoccupare ti porterò
da lei una volta che sarà tutto finito è
stronzo pure quella lì mannaia la morte
para que me bruttissimo queste torture
per i bambini ma no dai
no mamma adesso hai capito chi è tuo
padre è dove ancora salvare
[Musica]
ma no ma povero già tuo padre gli ha
fatto male non farlo anche noi di farli
ma neanche tu mamma mamma
poverino mi dispiace tantissimo ma che
cosa bruttissima o che in gioco è questo
non lo ricordavo fosse così ci devo
tornare porca vacca velocemente anche
c'è gente fuori
no è sparito il bambino come volevo
tornare a salvarti c'è qualcosa qui un
ciondolo che una ragnatela enorme tra
che schifo aragno non ci puoi passare
sotto tipo no ha tra l'altro fosse
provare usare il coltello no eccolo si è
rotto lo spi sono guardato allo specchio
si è rotto lo specchio non faccio così
schifo dai park cav h
ho trovato la cosa ne armani un
accendino vuoto ok selezione 6 scatolare
il gas dell'accendino posso entrare in
teoria di sotto se le cose non uccidono
prima via via via via veloce veloce
veloce veloce se questo guadagni anno è
passato perfetto qui posso andare
soprattutto così era la stanza delle
bambole va bene cos'è sta roba orribile
ma se si muovono così dettagliata sembra
non sembra neanche una bambola bambola
decorativa un'agenda ok per aprire tende
e niente poi c'è qualcosa lo vedo sono
due bambole va bene niente niente
tranquilla le bambole hanno un sorriso
krypi vuol dire tipo spaventi critica
non sorriso che cosa devo fare qua
me ne vado giustamente ciao stato bello
avente la stanza delle bambole buono a
sapersi
il tipo dove c'è un passaggio segreto lo
sapevo
e stato un agente ma non c'era niente
c'era solo la gemma va bene niente male
cioè il codice meno ce l'hai r leggilo
tu che ne so io a nomi indica degli
oggetti 1 i barili nel primo piano nella
stanza est
devo contarli 1234567 sono 7 quindi
primo numero e 7 il secondo numero è 787
48 e di quadri nella stanza della
reception uno è rotto e l'altro è quindi
74 82 giusto ci proviamo a salire le
scale difficilissimo perché se
continuate andare dritto non le sale e
stranissimo sto gioco fighissimo
fighissimo una sega perché la mente
difficoltà per 74 82 giusto 74 82 se non
sbagliato niente avrebbe senso
let's go se aperto perfetto contiene le
cose di mamma c'è una lampada qui ho
finalmente è molto buio quindi dovrei
avere una luce è perfetto mai prendi la
la prendo solo in prestito ma sì sì sì
intanto vai nella botola
leggo quindi ragazzi spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto sono veramente super
contento aveva riportato matt father sul
canale perché ci giocavo da una vita
quindi non mi ricordo niente ma poi è
l'anno tutto rimasterizzato e proprio
tutto nuovo quindi anche diverso ci sta
proprio in fatto di rigiocarlo veramente
fighissimo ovviamente per tutti quelli
che non lo conoscevo non aspettatevi una
grandissima serie io spero che vi sia
piaciuto come momento mi piace anche a
vari soci perché come una descrizione se
non siete ci vediamo ma non proseguito
da ragazzi